الآن مع دول مثل الولايات المتحدة والمملكة
المتحدة والهند ،
بدأت جميع حملات التطعيم ، هناك
الكثير من الأسئلة حول
الوصول العادل للأشخاص في الدول النامية ،
فقد لا يتمكنون ببساطة من الحصول على
اللقاحات لأن البلدان الأكثر ثراء تأخذ
ما تحتاجه أولاً في بعض الحالات
أكثر مما تحتاجه  وفقًا
لمجموعة مراقبة اللقاحات الدولية
في 67 دولة فقيرة ، يمكن لواحد فقط من كل 10
أشخاص أن يأمل في الحصول على لقاح
بحلول نهاية العام المقبل ، تمتلك البلدان التي
تمثل 14 بالمائة فقط من
سكان العالم
أكثر من نصف اللقاحات الواعدة
في الواقع التي اشترتها كندا  جرعات كافية
لتحصين المواطنين خمس مرات أكثر من
توم بويك هو مدير الصحة العالمية
في مجلس العلاقات الخارجية
وهو ينضم إلي الآن
من واشنطن وشكراً جزيلاً
على القيام بذلك ، أردت أن أبدأ بشيء
كتبته في Foreign Affairs.com
سأقتبس من ذلك
اللقاح القومي أو أن
النهج الأول في بلدي
للتخصيص سيكون له عواقب عميقة
بعيدة المدى
أخبرنا عن تلك
العواقب فتلك العواقب أه
تبدأ بإطالة أمد
الوباء باتباع نهج حيث تعامل هذا
الفيروس وكأن حدود وطنية جديدة هي
الطريقة
الخاطئة للذهاب أه السماح للفيروس
بالانتشار دون هوادة يعني أنه سيكون لديه
صحة أكبر
عواقب اقتصادية أكبر ولكن هذا في
النهاية سيجعل حتى الدول التي لديها
لقاحات أقل
أمانًا لأننا لن نتمكن من
تطعيم
سكاننا بالكامل لفترة أه
من الوقت
أه كما رأينا في الأسابيع الأخيرة
كانت هناك طفرات
لذلك  كما أن السماح بانتشاره في مكان آخر
يزيد من مخاطر ذلك ،
لكن النقطة الأخيرة التي أعتقد أنها
مهمة حقًا
أن يفهمها المشاهدون هي إذا لم نتمكن من
التعاون
على التوزيع العادل للقاح
في خضم جائحة قاتلة عندما
يكون
من مصلحتنا جميعًا  التعاون في ما هو
التحدي العالمي الذي سنكون قادرين على
التعاون بشأنه بحيث يقوض آفاقنا
في العمل معًا كدول
لمنع  الوباء القادم
أو تحديات أخرى مثل تغير
المناخ وهذه نقطة جيدة حقًا
ربما تكون أكبر نقطة ،
أعني أن CNN ذكرت أن
الدول الغنية قد اشترت ما يكفي من
جرعات اللقاح
لتحصين سكانها ثلاث مرات أكثر
مما يمكن أن تفعله الدول النامية في الواقع.
يعانون من الوباء
بخلاف
رفع أيديهم وآمل أن يظهر شخص ما
تعاطفًا ،
لذا فإن الخيارات التي يؤسفني أن أقول إن
اللقاحات المحدودة تختلف اختلافًا جوهريًا
عن الأدوية الجزيئية الصغيرة مثل أدوية فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية تلك
التي قد يتذكرها بعض المشاهدين أن معظم
البلدان لا تستطيع صنعها
وستكون كذلك  خذ وقتًا لتوسيع
القدرة التصنيعية
اللازمة للقيام بذلك ، لذا فإن الخيارات المتاحة
للدول الفقيرة بدون لقاحات هي حقًا
ذات شقين
أحدهما هو زيادة الضغط
كما اقترحت
رفع يديك وزيادة
الضغط على الدول للمشاركة
في المبادرة المتعددة الأطراف.
الحصول على الموارد
التي تحتاجها تلك المبادرة متعددة الأطراف المسماة
kovacs  تنجح
الثانية أنها يمكن أن تلجأ إلى مصادر
اللقاحات المتوفرة لهم
والتي من المحتمل في هذه الحالة أن تكون
لقاحات من الصين وروسيا
التي أه تعلمون شريطة أن يتم
التحقق
منهم بشكل مستقل أنها تمر عبر القنوات التنظيمية الصحيحة
أه أن  سيكون رائعًا ولكن في الوقت الحالي
لم تفعل أيًا من تلك اللقاحات ، لذا
فهو مقلق
نعم والنوع الآخر منكم يعرف
الواقع بالطبع هو أن
شركات الأدوية ليست
جمعيات خيرية هل تتوقعون أن
شركات الأدوية ربما
أه تضع ربحًا أه جانبًا أو تضعها
أولاً عندما يتعلق الأمر بالدول التي
تعرف أنها لا تستطيع تحمل
التكلفة الباهظة لشراء اللقاح أو
توزيعه ،
إذا كان الأمر كذلك ، أعتقد أن
شركات الأدوية
تريد فعلاً فعل الشيء الصحيح
هنا ، والسبب هو أنهم لا
يريدون التكرار
من سيناريو فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية الذي أشرت إليه
قبل
20 عامًا ،
وجدت شركات الأدوية نفسها
في الجانب الخطأ من دعوى قضائية مع حكومة
جنوب إفريقيا  قلق بشأن الوصول إلى
الأدوية يسمى
39 شركة أدوية ضد نيلسون
مانديلا ،
فهم لا يريدون سيناريو آخر مثل
ذلك التحدي الذي
حدث هو أن معظم مخزوناتهم
قد تم
شراؤها وأن القدرة على تصنيع اللقاحات
شحيحة حقًا ،
وسيستغرق الأمر جهدًا لتجربته  لتوسيع
هذه الخيارات ، حتى أن شركة فايزر
عرضت بيع
50 مليون جرعة للدول الأفريقية
من لقاحها ، ولكن بسبب متطلبات سلسلة التبريد
، يجب أن تبقى في
درجة حرارة منخفضة لتوزيعها ، لقد كانوا
مترددين
في القيام بذلك.  هناك صعوبة حقيقية في
إيصال الإمدادات إلى
حيث يحتاجون إلى الذهاب في أقرب وقت ، نعم ، نعم ،
يأمل المرء ألا يسود الموقف "أنا أولاً"
لأن بلايين الأشخاص سيعانون
بخلاف
ذلك ، شكراً
جزيلاً للتحدث إلينا ،
شكراً جزيلاً على  استضافتي